it's great to be joined today by
stephanie kelton who's a professor of
public policy and economics at Stony
Brook University she also served as
chief economist on the US Senate Budget
Committee in 2015 and was an economic
adviser to the Bernie Sanders 2016
presidential campaign it's so great to
talk to you we are going to talk about
modern monetary theory once again of
course our audience knows that we
recently spoke to Pavlina chernova about
this we are now really getting to the
end of this potentially significant
change to the American tax code and one
of the discussions that we had a little
bit with Pavlina and I'd love to expand
on with you is the discussion of the
impact on the deficit of this plan
stated plainly should that be a
consideration when we think about tax
priorities well only to the extent that
politically adding to the deficit
charges the debate and and you know
there are things that adding to the
deficit could do like for example lead
to Republicans saying that they've got
to make cuts to Medicare or something
these are political considerations not
economic considerations so with that
caveat in mind I would say that for the
most part the discussions and the
objections Democrats are raising to the
Trump tax cuts on the grounds that they
add to the deficit is really quite
beside the point yeah and in fact a lot
of the discussion around debt and
deficit seems to be the pointing out of
the heap the hypocrisy of when that is
invoked in some sense I mean we know
that we have some Republican senators
who have previously vowed never to vote
for any tax plan that increases the
deficit by a penny bob Corker comes to
mind I think Rand Paul has made similar
comments about the deficit and yet now
they seem not to care about that
Democrats on the other hand often don't
talk about the debt or deficit when
they're talking about programs but now
that it's Republicans who want to do it
are talking about it it's sort of a
punching bag political issue in a sense
isn't it definitely I mean it's
definitely a political football you're
absolutely right both sides you
use this as an expedient way to try to
score a quick point against the other
team when they're raising objections to
whatever agenda it is they're trying to
push oh but this is terrible because
it's going to add to the deficit as if
this is something that really resonates
with voters that you know when you raise
concerns about the national debt or
deficits that this is the best most
effective way to get voters riled up and
behind you as you oppose a piece of
legislation I really think it's terribly
misguided voters for the most part don't
have the slightest idea a what the
national debt is what the deficit is and
they really don't care what number ends
up showing up on some government ledger
somewhere as long as they're doing okay
in their lives so if the government is
doing something that adds to the deficit
but in the end people feel better off
about their own job security maybe they
see their wages going up they feel like
they're living in a better economy they
really don't care that the government is
added to the deficit it's more about you
know what what is happening in voters
own lived experiences in the economy
that's the kind of thing that matters
right if you tell people you're gonna
lose your health care you're gonna that
stuff matters you can get voters and
that's why I think you know when
Republicans were trying to do the repeal
and replace the opposition was so strong
right because you know the the
Congressional Budget Office looked at
this and when they looked at what
Republicans wanted to do actually it
would have quote improved the deficit
deficits would have been smaller as a
result of the Republicans throwing
millions of people off health care but
the Democrats didn't say oh they're
doing this and it's going to shrink the
size of the deficit they said they're
doing this and it's going to throw
millions of people off their health care
and people stood up and said over my
dead body we're not doing this right and
that put enough political pressure on
Republicans in the end they were unable
to do this so it's not it's not about
the deficit that I think is not the way
to the hearts and minds of the American
people one of the reactions that a lot
of our audience had after we talked a
little bit about this with Pavlina turn
Ava was the inflationary aspect and to
take to take ideally the the most top
level view of this even for the economic
sort of layperson
I think a lot of us could understand why
if you just start printing money if you
put more dollars in circulation or
whatever term you want to use for this
and you have holding your holding steady
the sort of economic output of a country
if you have more of these dollars each
dollar would be worth less or to put in
a different way
prices might go up there would be
inflation to account for the fact that
each dollar might be worth less what's
the simplest way to explain to someone
who is again not not who's an economic
lay person why that would not happen if
we were to say create a job guarantee
universal basic income pay for universal
health care whatever program we might
imagine well I think that it depends a
lot on what the program is some of the
things that you mentioned I think we can
we can do without resulting in the kind
of inflation problem that you're
describing as a possibility other
programs I'm not so sure it depends on
the type of program you mentioned the
universal basic income one of the things
that proponents of the ubi often do is
say well everybody should get a living
wage the equivalent of a living wage and
sometimes they'll throw around a number
like thirty thousand dollars a year just
send everybody a check for $30,000 a
year so they have a basic income to get
by on well if you actually run the
numbers that turns out to be a humongous
increase in total spending so if you're
gonna add 30 or 40 percent of GDP to the
economy and not do something to offset
that then I think you're gonna get a
pretty major inflation problem so it
does depend on the kind of program what
you're describing is a problem that
arises when as Milton Friedman sort of
you know the Chicago School of Economics
when Friedman described inflation as
always in everywhere a monetary
phenomenon and he said it's too much
money chasing too few goods okay if
you're doing something in the economy
whether it's a job guarantee program
large-scale infrastructure program
making public colleges and universities
tuition-free whatever it is that you're
doing if you're running up against the
real constrain
in the economy where you don't have the
people and the factories and the
machines that capacity the raw materials
for government to take a larger share of
what the economy has available and to
spend into that economy if those things
aren't available you're gonna end up
bidding up prices but if you're talking
about doing things in a very deliberate
way where you're mindful of how many raw
materials do we have do we have the
people do we have the capacity how much
additional infrastructure spending could
we do in America without creating
bottlenecks in in the production process
without causing an inflation problem you
always have to be aware of those kinds
of considerations so after we started
talking about MMT I had a lot of people
who emailed me and said David you need
to ask stephanie kelton about
cryptocurrency Bitcoin and others
because the explanation for why MMT
would work is or can be applied to why
allegations that bitcoin or whatever
cryptocurrency have no intrinsic value
are debunk Abel do you have a strong
sense of that how does mmt and the sort
of underlying theory behind it connect
to the existence or lack of intrinsic
value or inherent value in Bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies yeah because well
from our perspective mmt likes to look
at the currency and say why does this
otherwise worthless piece of paper why
does it have value why are people
willing to give up a portion of their
day working and producing in order to
get this otherwise worthless thing
called a US dollar right it's just an
intrinsically worthless piece of paper
except that it's not worthless right and
and so the question becomes why does the
US dollar have value why are people
willing to work and produce in order to
get this thing and mmt has always
connected the value of the currency to
the fact that we the people need the
government's money in order to settle
obligations to the government in order
to pay taxes and other fees and things
to government so ultimately the US
dollar is backed by taxes it's backed by
the government's ability to make
right contracts and produce and pay
taxes in this currency called the US
dollar Bitcoin doesn't have that it
doesn't have anybody standing behind it
enforcing rules and laws and requiring
people to make payments with this form
of currency so it's purely voluntary in
that respect right yeah I mean I think
to play devil's advocate there would be
the counter-argument that while you
don't have a government behind it you do
have the infrastructure of the
blockchain you've sort of decentralized
the authority behind it and that in a
sense again I'm playing devil's advocate
here the defenders would say that's more
valuable because you don't have any
single entity in control of it yeah it's
more valuable to people who want that
sort of anonymity and so you know at the
in the early stages I think a lot of
people were very aware that you know a
lot of the activity that was going on
using Bitcoin was the kind of activity
that people don't want the government or
anybody else to be aware because it's
not legal and so yeah I mean on that I
would want to see some data only because
I've researched that aspect a little bit
I mean I think earlier on in Bitcoin
when the Silk Road was shut down which
was this kind of like dark web hub for
the sale of everything from you know
assassination contracts and more
commonly drugs
there was a ver was a very small change
in the amount of Bitcoin being
transacted and that sort of implied that
maybe the the illegal uses for it were
not as big as was being mentioned but in
any case it's not really our primary
conversation here but point taken
yeah I mean the bottom line is that
there isn't that anchor with respect to
Bitcoin that there is with respect to a
currency like the US dollar or the
British Pound or the yen or a national
currency it just lacks that that
government backing that maintains the
value of the currency so the value of
the US dollar is never going to go to
zero as long as you have a government
that's able to make an enforce tax laws
the value of Bitcoin could theoretically
go to zero there's nothing to prevent
that from happening
what would your feelings about its
viability change
if it was more widely accepted not
necessarily by governments but by all
but by people in other words if the
number of people in the market cap of it
continued to increase and it did start
to be accepted as a form of payment
would that change your mind on it or is
it based on the fundamentals of its
structure that you're that you're
feeling this way I don't know that I
have my mind made up on it in some
respects so I think it's an a
fascinating thing that we're all getting
to watch you know what's happening with
these crypto currencies in bit point you
can Bitcoin in particular and to the
extent that it actually begins to
function in the ways that early on you
know people said it was going to be an
important means of exchange we're not
really seeing that but I think if we do
begin to see that happening it's going
to be fascinating to watch and yeah I
can I can definitely change my
perspective of the usefulness of this
cryptocurrency and others like it as we
watch this experiment unfold I just
don't have really strong opinions on it
one way or another yet to circle back
more specifically to at least the US
government and its relationship to debt
deficit and the ideas of modern monetary
theory is there any particular policy
sort of to round out our conversation
that you think that if we could get
wholesale sort of buy-in and
understanding of the principles of mmt
there was one policy that it would point
to our legislators enacting that would
most benefit society is there something
you have in mind I think probably the
one that I would go to is the federal
job guarantee I mean this is the this is
the kind of cornerstone policy in a
sense with the MMT school of thought the
basic idea here is that there's no other
economic school of thought that has a
solution for the problem of involuntary
unemployment not a single one and so the
best that you can do in any of the
mainstream approaches to economics is to
say to the central bank you know target
the unemployment rate keep the level of
unemployment at just the right level so
that we prevent inflation from
accelerating above 2% per year in other
words were
lying on policymakers to maintain a
certain amount of unemployment in the
system as a guard against inflation and
what mmt does is say that's
extraordinarily inefficient
it's very wasteful there are costs borne
not just you know in terms of lost
output but a variety of social costs as
well that the economy would function
better that we would have a more
prosperous economy if we
institutionalize full employment and the
way to do that is through a federally
funded but locally administered jobs
program and it would just make the
overall economy function better because
what it does is it takes the automatic
stabilizers the features that are
already there today to help cushion the
economy as it goes through the
inevitable you know booms and busts of a
business cycle and it turbo charges the
automatic stabilizer makes them stronger
so that when we have a downturn the
unemployment rate recovers more quickly
it's not as lasting it's not as deep
look at what happened in the Great
Recession right it took nine years to
claw back all the jobs that were lost so
I think that's probably if I have to
pick one that's the policy that I'm most
enthusiastic about we've been speaking
with stephanie kelton professor of
public policy and economics at Stony
Brook University I really appreciate you
talking to me today
do you're very welcome thanks for having
me